only on CBS this morning Dylan Farrow
addresses the alleged sexual abuse by
her father actor and director Woody
Allen for 25 years Dylan Farrell has
insisted her adopted father sexually
assaulted her when she was a little girl
she says she felt ignored and she's now
speaking on camera about the allegations
for the first time in this preview of
our conversation she explains why now is
the time to talk someone said this to me
she wants to bring Woody Allen down
she's caught up in the me - times up
movement and this is really what she's
trying to do is bring him down why
shouldn't I want to bring him down why
shouldn't I be angry why shouldn't I be
hurt
why shouldn't I feel some sort of
outrage that after all these years being
ignored and disbelieved and tossed aside
and after all these years why should
people believe you now I suppose that's
on them but all I can do is speak my
truth and hope hope I hope that somebody
will believe me instead of just hearing
we of course have reached out to Woody
Allen through his representatives and we
are waiting for his response it's
important to note that no criminal
charges were ever filed against Allen
and he has always denied the accusations
you can see more of our interview with
Dylan Farrow tomorrow find out why she
believes one sexual assault victim is
enough to change the national
conversation about abuse that's tomorrow
on CBS this morning
it's incredible to hear her speaking out
front it really is but you know what she
says Nora she says I have been speaking
out no one's been listening uh but for
the first time she's on on Cameron she
says maybe it will make a difference
when people can see my face and see how
I'm feeling and see what I believe will
see
people are listening with new years
that's also true also true job